shuffling to safety one train carriage
roof
at a time these passengers are being
rescued from taiwan's deadliest railway
disaster in decades
all of a sudden i just fell from my seat
to the ground i hit my head and saw it
was bleeding
the train crowded with more than 400
people
derailed in a tunnel after slamming into
a truck
that rolled onto the tracks from a
nearby construction site
the impact ripped some carriages apart
and crumpled
others
rescuers worked for hours to reach
trapped passengers
many of whom were rushed to hospital
many people were crushed under train
seats from the collision
and there were others on top of the
seats so those at the bottom were
crushed and lost consciousness
the accident comes at the start of a
busy annual long holiday weekend
when taiwan's roads and railways are
usually packed
investigations into the cause of the
crash are ongoing
correspondent joyce lee is standing by
for us inside the hospital where the
seriously injured are being treated
close to the crash site uh
what can you tell us about the injured
so there uh it is a total of uh
150 injured um in the accident
and 55 of them were sent here to
um this major hospital in hawaiian city
um and uh 17 of them are still here at
the hospital
and two of them are still in the
intensive care unit
and unfortunately a six-year-old girl
died in the hospital and her uh 12 year
old sister
is still in the icu um their
grandparents
uh rushed to the hospital taking a taxi
for over eight hours to come here uh to
attend to them
and it is a belief that our president
changing
will come and visit the wounded tomorrow
morning
george can you give us more detail
details on what exactly
has happened to that train
so the train uh was heading to the
um east uh south south
eastern uh taiwan tai tong city um
but then a construction vehicle
was believed to have
not parked properly and it slid down to
the slope
and hit the train passing by
and four carriages uh were stuck
in the tunnel and um the authorities
said that
they were actually uh deformed so many
people
were trapped inside the carriages
and talking about the people trapped
inside the carriages what is going to
happen in the coming
hours are there still passengers
unaccounted for
all the injured are already sent to sex
hospitals and being treated for
so um the authorities are trying to
clear the track so that um
the train could pass by smoothly because
the holiday is would go until a monday
so it is important that the traffic will
not be blocked by the train
uh joyce how have the people of taiwan
reacted
to this uh terrible news
they are very shocked and very saddened
by the news because this is the
first day of the um long weekend
of the timing festival where people
usually
go back to their hometown and reunite
with their family and
pay respect to their ancestors so this
is a very very sad news
in taiwan dw correspondent
joyce lee thank you very much